we had some calls that came in I wanted
to hear how different places in the
world were dealing with and in in in
what Yorker what your corona was like
your corona time and so we got some
calls that came in here right here
this is Nicole from Malaysia in
beautiful place over there Malaysia and
I sexually saw a couple of monkeys over
there steal a bag of chips from a thick
thick urban chicken um and they went at
least two rounds but you thought it was
going to end there but you know a big
girl don't wanna lose that's that chip
sac gang [ __ ] homeward hey Theo it's the
cold calling from Penang Malaysia hey
Nicole
and thank you for calling in from Penang
there and Malaysia I don't know I've
been to Malaysia actually I just told
you that and it's a man it's like the
beach went to the beach that's how
that's how beachy it is and it is it's
humid you know I remember I took my
shirt off and they had two goldfish
swimming in my bellybutton I mean it's
that it's humid you'll find a damn
starfish come out from under yawn onward
internationally we're still in
quarantine over here and we probably
will be until the end of Ramadan which
is near the end of May because they're
real worried about people having large
gatherings for Ramadan since it's a
majority Muslim country shout out
Muslims brother shout out Slim's baby
all day home word so even though we
don't have a lot of cases at all we're
gonna be in lockdown for a while longer
which sucks and I'm a senior in high
school so we're all just hoping that
they'll ease up on the restrictions and
time for us to have graduation because
we really don't want to miss that it's
crazy here because it's actually illegal
to exercise outside so we can't run or
walk or dogs or bike outside at all and
I got stopped by the police for going on
a run by myself so you can't really be
outside at all unless you have evidence
that you're going to the groceries
and that's the only time one can be
outside so that kind of sucks because
we're really locked in here Wow well
thank you Nicole thanks for uh for that
message Wow
I can't believe you guys are really I
mean you can't even take a dog yeah I
guess you just have to have a dog just
teach a dog to what urinate inside or
use a toilet Wow
that's badass insane but um but that's
beautiful I'm glad that you know I'm
glad that that's that you know you guys
are able to I guess help the animals
like that but yeah I mean that makes me
think at least I can go for a run you
know and why you can't exercise you got
stopped by the police for just for
fitness knew that reminds me one time I
was jogging in the Midwest and I was in
a real and that's the real thick belt
and if you've been to the Midwest but
damn you won't I mean you'll have a
thigh you know your Thyle just show up
out of nowhere they got a dam somebody
down you know you'll see a some fella
got hamstrings with real ham on them
like boy that's a salty bass as salty
backstrap and i was going for a jog and
somebody stopped some guys like I'm he
pulled over he's like you okay what's
happening buddy all right what's going
on
what another calmness you know what are
you running from man you scared of
something like nah man I'm this fitness
buddy
I'm doing I'm doing Fitness I'm an adult
man but wow we're really putting that in
perspective and you to be in school and
not know if you'll be able to have that
graduation experience Wow
mmm you know that puts it into
perspective for me for sure
you know we've got a lot to be grateful
for and you know I'm sorry I'm sorry
that you're dealing with that your
attitude seems really good though Nicole
I appreciate you sharing that with with
with me and and you know and just
sharing a little bit of what's going on
over there and then wow yeah if it comes
in a religious territory which I like
you know I like there being some
religion and you didn't sound negative
about it and I appreciate that you know
not that you would but you know I like I
think it's a good time for people to
have faith and and the fact that you
know people are gonna say okay not only
have I been going through this but that
doesn't negate that I'm gonna try and
still have my faith you know because if
I you know what I'm saying I've been a
half I've been one of those kind of
half-breed Christians you know where I
you know you know my faith is always you
know I grew up I didn't really have a
lot you know how do I was around a lot
of it and we would go to church and
stuff but in my heart I didn't really
know much but so that's real special
that people are able to have faith and
and and you know that they're not
letting that discount saying okay well
look how you know we did the core of it
so now we don't have to do you know we
don't have to do the fast and we don't
have to do this or that that's pretty
powerful but thank you thank you for
that update from from the Malay the
Malay people over there beautiful
alright let's take another call here and
this is from prag right here and this is
Sean Hoffman
let's go Hotch hey this is Sean and then
Prague in the Czech Republic thank you
for calling Sean from Czech Republic and
when I actually visited there they had a
man pickpocketed me and this guy was
small this guy had the smallest damn
hands bro you couldn't even
I mean this guy oh no one you could
barely fit you know he could put dude he
could almost put both hands and both
feet in your pocket and you couldn't
feel it think about that think about
having four appendages in a damn pant
pocket and you can and feel the person
in there and that's dark magic right
there let's hear more I wanted to see
how things wear elsewhere in the world
I've been on lockdown for about six
weeks now things are slowly starting to
get back to normal as you can see
there's a whole bunch of other people
out here on the bridge still everybody
wears their masks outside but people are
starting to go back out to the parks
some of the stores are up and backed up
and I think by the middle of June things
might be yet getting back to being more
or less normal
looks like the borders are gonna be
closed for the rest of the summer but
maybe after this is all done you can
find another European tour love to see
you gang thanks Shaun interesting so
yeah that sounds pretty similar I think
things are starting to loop people
people are starting to loosen up make
the choice
some people you know and and that's what
life is like that is just a you know
it's a lot of just Hansel and Gretel n'
that's who we are really we you know
we're curious creatures
damnit I'm sorry Sean but yeah you get
that you know people I noticed it too
the traffic's getting more in Los
Angeles people are doing more things
more thoughts trying to holler more gay
dudes even you know out here in LA
there's a thing now if you go running if
you go running on your feet and without
a mask that is a apparently it's like a
pickup thing for men that like other
that like other men and so it's like the
new member if you used to put your foot
out under the bathroom stall wall in
Minnesota or whatever you know you used
to drop that boot over there and that
other do
little [ __ ] and then bang him next
thing you know y'all playing freaking
hide that Rodney um but what was
original note but what I'm telling you
is or what I'm what I'm sharing right
now is just that yeah people are gonna
make their own choices and so I you
don't understand when some people are
like we need liber8 we need to you know
I was talking to my brother-in-law or
something I think it might be second
cousins or not second cousins but I
don't know Sumati [ __ ] somebody
honestly and that's how we're you know
cousin in law and he was saying well
like you have counties in Texas where
they had four cases of it so what do
those people do like they you know how
do they get back to work how do they
they can't start their universe back up
so it's tricky man it's tricky to see
but I think humans you know we're gonna
have our own sense at a certain point of
wins okay to venture back out and to get
things poppin and uh you know feel the
world and know if it's safe and know if
it's safe for us and what our love would
what's safe for me you know I'm risky
you know I'm that risky biscuit you know
what I'm saying you could put jam on me
bro you could put pepper you could put
down rubber cement on my back you know
what I'm saying I'm still a snack dog so
gang [ __ ] you feel me but uh but thank
you for sharing this beautiful and if
you and both um both of these call these
last two callers were from on video so
if you're watching on youtubes you can
see these peoples beautiful faces and
and and showing us from right here on a
famous bridge right there in Prague let
me see famous bridge in Prague
and that bridge is called the charles
bridge named after a white so beautiful
man thank you brother thanks for calling
in and be safe over there and and and
yes definitely it's like people's idea
of what safe is different people's idea
of what safe is different I did read on
that the there are now 50,000 deaths in
the u.s. from Corbin nineteen
coronavirus and you and every year the
pneumonia gets that many people as well
every year pneumonia does and I really
believe that if we didn't have if twenty
years ago this happened I don't think
you would have heard anything about it I
really don't I don't think you would
have heard anything about it I think it
would have just been like oh this year
is a strong flu season we have a flu
that's lasted late and that's I think
that that's where it kind of would have
landed but now you have the 24-hour news
cycle so you got to fill that news Bank
you have to do it there used to be two
hours of news there was morning news and
there was evening news and then they
would do a late evening in case she was
by over you know you had a little side
piece over and y'all wanted to do you
know we'll look at something before
y'all went over there and touched each
other's bodies or something or split a
steak or something but but now it's 24
so so they used to be able to pack the
whole news into those three hours and
some of the stories would double over
now there's 21 more hours of news so
they got to fill that with something and
that
think hysteria really began where the
news is like okay what can we do what's
and then at a certain point what's
selling for us what's keeping people
hooked on the screen so I really believe
that and and I really believe that if we
didn't have the 24-hour news cycle that
we wouldn't that this would just be kind
of a strong flu season that it came and
gone now I know that this is stronger
this has a ha this thing has a higher
kill rate than other than other flus but
but I just think it that's what it would
have been but hey what do I know right
and I might be wrong also so really good
chance of that let's take one more video
call that came in and this is gentleman
from Dubai right here gang what's up do
this is hunter checking in from Dubai
you not what's up honored thank you for
checking in brother from Dubai
onward lien American better live here
full-time now I just wanted to give you
some insight on what's going down in
this country it's pretty strict right
now we have handled it well and it's
been kind of contains one is your area
the city I mean everywhere else is doing
pretty good but you have to apply for a
permit
anytime you go outside anytime and now
they've restricted it's where you can
only leave and go places every three
days so we're kind of just huddled up
hunkered down but shout out to companies
like cream and somato that's like our
version of posts mates they're
delivering the food still other than
that device interesting it's a
definitely still kind of a third world
country scenario but pre kovat it was
very almost over employed there's
virtually no I want to
no homelessness to that though there is
a dark side these guys aren't these guys
from like Karachi Pakistan Dhaka
Bangladesh in various places like that
they're just they're not getting paid
well and it's rough living scenarios and
because of this and now they're just not
working at all so there's actually been
a spike in homelessness and people who
are stranded and the airports are closed
too they can't get back to their home
country so that is a sad thing to see
but other than that we're holding it
down thanks for everything you do Gang
Gang Green gang bro Thank You hunter
for that message man and that's
information as well as a message Wow
yeah you don't think of that you know I
mean it's I mean or you do think of it
maybe you do that the whole way you know
it's in every place it's it's going on
and I'm not trying it this isn't like a
I'm not trying to make this be a downer
thing I'm trying to just share what it's
like from around the globe you know you
know I'm not trying to make us feel bad
about anything I'm not trying to feel
bad about it you know this is what life
is life is
I mean life think about what life has
been for some people I think about some
man was born imagine this some man was
born somewhere in a forest maybe or you
know in like a dead like a like a thick
thick thick forest and he don't know
anything and he you know he grows up and
he doesn't his parents don't have much
money or whatever and he to say he does
woodworking he does basic stuff and then
he you know one day he sees maybe like
you know he sees like a beautiful bird
or something maybe you're robbing like a
Red Robin a red breasted
Robin and and that's like that's like
his the best part of his life and he and
then he dies and his family dies and and
that's his life his life with that one
thing when he saw that Robin it was
everything for him that was his that was
his you know having a family that was
his prom that was his you know getting
married that was his that was his that
was the that was it that was his his
life and that's a life that's a that
that's a beautiful life that's in its
own place the Robin man but it's
different when you get you know we're
used to like fancier lives getting to do
this and getting to do that and and now
some of that has just been adjusted but
thank you for that information from
there from Dubai and what it's like and
that while being stranded I would hate
that that would be tough man because
people gonna do what they're gonna do at
a certain point people want to bub
little Charlie gonna buck little Asad
gonna buck little yeehaw over here or
chin you know little chinstrap or
whatever your boys name is Viet people
gonna get bucked off somebody's gonna
[ __ ] hum a glass bottle it at a jogger
you know the same people gonna start to
bend a little and see what they can read
evening good afternoon and other times
thanks for watching that video you just
saw I mean it was okay but the next
video you can watch could be way better
what if you watch a video right now that
changes your life well you could watch
this one or watch this one watch this
one watch this one watch this one